[Music]
good evening thank you for coming to the
first talk of what I think is our 15th
season thank you and I wanted to thank
all of you members and donors who helped
us in our end of year campaign it's
really making events like these possible
sf Jazz is very generous in their
relationship with us in this series but
it's still a very expensive series to
put on so thank you very much we very
much appreciate it
as many of you know we do a what's
called a long short as the beginning of
these talks a short film that in some
way exemplifies long-term thinking this
one Andrew and our office found and is
kind of a template of walk through the
history of the relationship of humanity
and the earth enjoy
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart Brandon from
long now and this is they actually we
got a guy at the beginning of his book
tour wizard and the Prophet is basically
launched tonight and big deal you get to
be part of this special occasion when we
get to hear a speaker who is not tired
of his subject yet and this particular
speaker is established himself as a
science journalist who does not think
small or research small or write small
he takes on civilizations sized subjects
planet-sized subjects and is definitely
doing so tonight nobody does it better
than Charles C man
[Applause]
well thank you so much for the kind
words you said about this man guy and if
I ever run into him I'll be sure to pass
them on thank you all for coming I
thought it might begin by telling a
little bit about how I got involved in
this subject and it was about ten years
ago that I finally read that book by Al
Gore about climate change I'm sitting in
a cafe in my town in Amherst
Massachusetts reading the book and
there's a tap of my shoulder and it's
this woman here Lynn Margulis a great
biologist who lives down the street from
me and Lynn sort of in her way is some
of you apparently know her snatch the
book from my hand and she looks at it
with great disdain and because I'm an
idiot I say what what what and she looks
and there's like a picture of an
endangered polar bear or something in it
and she says you know mammals and the
reason that she says this is that she's
a microbiologist very famous one
National Academy of Sciences Crawford
Prize Presidential Medal of Science you
name it
and she's one of the people who's
established that sort of 99% of the
world's biomass is you know bacteria and
protists and fungi and algae and this
sort of thing and that 99% of the
world's evolutionary creativity is there
and that we mammals are basically just
epiphenomena you know they're cute she
would say you guys are cute but not much
and I feel you know stupidly I decided
to get defend us mammals and I say look
don't you think would be like sad if
people got wiped out by climate change
and she looks at me pityingly and she
says look it's the fate of every
successful species to wipe itself out
and the weird thing is I know what she's
talking about and what she's talking
about is basically the second Copernican
revolution now the first Copernican
revolution is this guy here Nicholas
Copernicus in he dissenters us as the
academic says he dissenters us
physically
he says the earth is not the center of
the universe it's not a special place
with its own set of special rules it's
just one of many places all governed but
the same physical laws it's just a tiny
dot among
other tiny dots which all are
fundamentally similar now ii Copernican
revolution is this guy Charles Darwin he
says Homo sapiens us were not the center
of creation we're not a special species
we don't have special laws that apply to
us alone we're just one of many species
all governed by the same set of
biological laws we're just a tiny dot
among all these other tiny dots in the
complicated Tree of Life and all the
rules apply to all the dots there's no
exceptions and that's the second
Copernican revolution and that's also
why ever since Darwin people are very
upset about evolution fundamentally it's
because we like to believe that we are
special and one thing that Lynne liked
to sort of drill into my little head was
no we are not special all the rules all
of them apply to us and this interview
was one of them drop a couple protozoa
in a petri dish filled with nutrient go
and watch what happens and what happens
is that there's a tiny video there's
only one special effect in this entire
show and it's this one right here and so
I'm gonna press this again and guess
what it's not gonna go I should say
I'm here in San Francisco it's the home
of people who believe in the singularity
that artificial intelligence is gonna
take over I will believe that when I am
able to get a PowerPoint video that I
had just turned on like 10 minutes ago
to show works and so if you were here
you'll be thrilled to see this these
guys multiplying multiplying and
multiplying until he hit the edge and
they either run out of nutrients or they
drown in their own waste they hit the
edge of the petri dish and very bad
things happen and the second Copernican
revolution says look this is what all
species do no exceptions including
people and thinking that were otherwise
it's foolish it means thinking that were
as Lynn would put it special and was
this true well here's a graph you've
probably seen before it's population
over time and if you look at this part
of it over here it looks like
unconstrained exponential growth it
looks like racing to the edge of the
petri dish and remember the laws of
biology are this doesn't end well now
it's not just population there's this
huge acceleration everything you've
imagined recently here's energy
consumption here's global per capita
income now I should say these are these
sort of fake money but the basic idea is
true but you actually have to go through
incredible conniptions to get a graph
like this and the concomitant of that is
global atmospheric co2 which is going up
and up all these things accelerating
here's global fresh water consumption
this is something that's sort of out of
left field but maybe you in California
know about this a little bit you know
the whole earth is enveloped by water
one of the things I was surprised by to
realize in this book is that the water
of course is just a thin skin on the
surface and if you bundle it all
together it gets to be something like
this it's a tiny sphere 860 miles or so
in diameter but 97% of that is saltwater
you can't undrinkable it's toxic if you
take the fresh water it's the second
sphere the 170 miles and most of that is
either locked up in glaciers or buried
deep underground or contaminated in one
way or another and so the usable supply
of actually accessible drinkable
freshwater is the tiny sphere of the
35-miles fear and so when you see this
sort of accelerating rise in consumption
of fresh water well you can see why
people look worried
so did Darwin get this one wrong I mean
right or is Lin Marquess wrong and if so
how do we avoid hitting the edge of the
petri dish now I'm gonna leave this
question hanging for a minute whether
it's all possible at all and and assume
the answer is yes then the question is
if we can escape biology
if Lin is wrong how do we do this and
basically when I talk to people I
realized after a while that there are
two basic answers that people come up
with and one of them is associated at
least in my mind with this guy and I
think if I was a technical person or a
philosopher or something I would call
Schumpeterian technically a Camellia ism
but I'm not going to inflict that on you
and so I just call him a wizard as in
techno wizard now Borlaug is my guy that
is an amazing guy he was born in this
very poor farmhouse that's it's one room
schoolhouse up there he hated the farm
where he worked like a dog and he hoped
to get out of it by being an athletic
scholarship played for the Chicago Cubs
he majors in forestry his first moose
family to go to university majors and
forestry because he likes the outdoors
he graduates in the middle of the
depression can't get a job sticks around
for his PhD it happens that his guy is
an Elvin Stegman a major figure in
American science and equally
accidentally he ends up in Mexico in
1944 on a statement project now at
Mexico that he is going to is not the
Mexico we know today it's desperately
poor about two-thirds of Mexicans at
some point in the year just don't get
enough to eat and the situation is
getting worse the maize which unicorn
which is sort of what most people in
Mexico eat the yields the farmers are
getting per acre are going down so that
even though they plant a million more
acres in 1940 than they did in 1920
there's about a third less maize to eat
things are really bad there and so what
the Rockefeller project that he's
working on Borlaug is working on is
trying to help Mexico with its corn
problem now he actually is working on
this little side project is with wheat
which a few Mexicans eat and is
afflicted by a fungus called stem rust
Poochyena gras - and it's a long term
predator on wheat it's been around so
that the Romans actually had a god of
stem rust that they would try to
propitiate obviously in vain and so he
is this sort of one-man scam rust
project and this is whole thing is an
absolutely ridiculous idea it's the
total folly Borlaug is no Spanish he's
never been outside the United States
he's never done any plant breeding he
has very little experience with wheat
and he's trying to do this without
knowing what DNA is he doesn't know what
a gene is because this is before Watson
and Crick and the wheat genome that he's
trying to play around with even though
he doesn't know what that's what he's
trying to do is way more complicated
than the human genome for example in
fact as Lynn liked to tell me plants are
just much more interesting than people
if you're a biologist you know wheat for
instance about five times as many genes
and because plants can do things
genetically that we can't it has three
complete copies of its genome and every
single cell and so it has roughly
speaking six copies of most genes in
every cell it's horribly complicated to
work with and in addition because the
Rockefeller people are trying not to
look like a gringo invasion they didn't
bring any they don't spend any money so
there's no tools there's no laboratory
that no buildings that don't even have
fields so Borlaug is there doing
something that's absolutely hopeless
with no knowledge of what's he doing but
the great thing is ignorance is bliss he
has no idea what a fool he's being so he
and two graduate students Mexican
graduate students go out into the field
from it and they collect eighty six
hundred varieties of wheat and then they
plant them all by hand and watch them
all by hand in this horrible hot weather
and bad conditions and they discover
that all but four are just wiped out by
stem rust and those four look really
terrible so rather than being depressed
he digs in and what he does is it comes
up with two ideas the first is high
volume cross breeding and what that
involves are taking all those 8600
varieties and then he gets more and you
plants about sixty thousand altogether
you plant them all individually by hand
remember doesn't have any quipment and
then what you do is you snip off this
little part on each one of each floor on
each one of those hundreds of thousands
of plants standing there in the hot Sun
and you emasculate them and then and
then you put to print them from being
remember being fertilized by pollen you
put these little paper sacks over them
and then you take the other half the
plants and you sprinkle the pollen on
them to create this and put the sacks on
you watch her and you record everything
it's a total nightmare and they're doing
it in awful conditions and then who
makes it even more difficult with a
second idea shuttle breeding and what
that is is there's two types of wheat
there's spring wheat and winter wheat
and winter wheat you plant in late fall
and it over winters as they say and then
you harvest it in the spring spring wait
you plant in the spring and you harvest
it in the in the fall and if if Borla
could ever gone to school
to study this he would have seen in the
textbooks that you cannot breed winter
wheat and spring wheat together because
they're supposed to grow in such
different conditions you have to grow
spring wheat over here it over there
winter wheat over there and that means
you can only do one breeding a year he
thinks well I'll just do one in spring
wheat here one in winter wheat here and
so in these two completely different
areas and I'll get all the conditions
and I'll have be able to do things twice
as fast and this is literally in the
textbook that you can't do this and in
fact the textbook owner the guy wrote
the textbook guy in hugh Hayes comes to
him in the middle of this and says what
are you doing and Borlaug throws a fit
and it's almost fired and some big mess
but he does it anyway and lo and behold
it turns out the textbooks are wrong and
he's incredibly lucky and so he develops
and really rapid speed twice as fast you
expect this rust resistant super
productive wheat that can grow almost
anywhere and give you some idea of how
poor this whole thing is these farm
equipment they actually borrowed them
from in this official picture from the
Rockefeller Foundation from a
neighboring farm because they didn't
have any of their own to try and make it
look like this is a major enterprise now
he's boardwalk happy that he has done
this no and the reason is logic what
happens is that he gets this super
productive wheat that responds very well
to to fertilizer and it grows and grows
grow so fast that the stocks become
spindly and then they have these big
heads of wheat on the top and they fall
over and if it's in the slightest wind
that crimps the stalk and that prevents
nutrients from going through and also
the grain rots on the ground and so the
farmers who eagerly embrace this then
can't harvest their their their wheat so
he steps in
keeps going he still working terrible
conditions
he gets his Japanese wheat that has been
a curiosity for a long time as dwarf
wheat that grows you know it's barely
this tall and well you can see how short
it is here these two wheats were planted
at the same time in the same place and
obviously one is much shorter and when
this he is able to combine this and work
it out what he gets is the what's called
the package the green revolution package
which is these hybrid seeds which are
disease resistant their short straw
there's something called photo period
insensitive which I'd be happy to tell
you about because I'm not going to do it
now maybe in the Q&A and then they
respond well to fertilizer this high
intensity nitrogen heavy fertilizers
made in factories and then you add in
irrigation and the results are
extraordinarily dramatic here you can
see the Mexican winter wheat yields and
basically they trundle along until the
late 50s and they suddenly take off and
Mexican farmers are able to grow about
four times as much wheat per acre as
they had been in the past and this isn't
just something for the poor the same
things happen over here and the reason
that the Middle West becomes this big
agricultural powerhouse for the world is
that these techniques which are applied
here and you can see them just
absolutely soaring in USDA figures it's
taken over to India this is what an
Indian wheat field looked in like
nineteen fifty when this famous
photographed by this famous photographer
Margaret bourke-white
and you see how I should ask have any of
you ever seen a wheat field yes okay the
reason is I gave a talk a while ago in
New York City and I asked this question
and not one person raised their hand
so I'm dealing with sophisticates here
so I'm totally relieved okay you know
that this is not a good looking wheel
field Road right okay and and the reason
is that this is partly deliberate and
that the place is so afflicted with stem
rust that they plant them very sparsely
in the vain hope that the that one plant
won't give stem rust to them to the to
the next plant then the Green Revolution
stuff comes in and the same thing
happens across all developing nations in
beginning in the mid 60s they absolutely
take off and it's very complicated and
difficult in a way to describe into a
vote for you what a big deal this is
and maybe this is why people don't that
often people don't even know what the
Green Revolution is now this is a bunch
of charts of average daily caloric
intake for places like the world India
in China and you see them all crawling
up by amount that doesn't seem all that
dramatic but maybe this can help these
dotted lines are what the USDA
recommends for moderately active women
and men and there's a whole long
digression you could go into about
whether they're accurate or not because
they're based on Iowa farm boys in the
1950s and these are for people in India
and China who are smaller and slightly
of stature and so we're but the basic
idea is that if you take this and you
take an average you want something like
24 or 2,500 calories for an average
person if you can assume that you can
blend together women and men and when
you do that you get something really
remarkable happening in the 1980s which
is that the average person in the world
or the average person in Asia for the
first time has enough to eat all the
time and it's unclear how how long it is
before this happens because
archaeologists and anthropologists argue
have a big lively argument about how
well hunter and gatherer ancestors did
this so the best I can say to you that
said this is unprecedented for thousands
of years the people just simply didn't
have enough to eat for basically all of
recorded human history and then it ends
here it's an enormous turning of the
page and there's a sort of a dim
recognition of this it's not as not near
classroom but you know you see
occasionally articles like this
there always say Borlaug saved a billion
lives and so forth and these not this
number is totally made-up but you get
the idea it was it was a very very big
deal but oh and because this is San
Francisco I'm going to assume that some
of you who have seen something like this
okay great great so this is actually
what corn looks like in its native
native state it's hilarious corn and if
you went to Mexico in the 60s and 70s it
would all look like this thousands of
different varieties it's an enormous
genetic treasure house agricultural
biodiversity is a sort of technical term
for it and what the Green Revolution
does is begin to shoulder that aside
and the Mexican grain harvest starts
looking like this this is a picture from
Sinaloa and tween and so there's a
tremendous genetic erosion now that's
not so bad sounding maybe we can put it
all this but then other problems that
come from it and this is all the part
where the but you know there's a the
Green Revolution is great but I forgot
to tell you that it's here that Green
Revolution involves putting massive
amounts of fertilizer on it and so this
increases a total amount of nitrogen
potassium and phosphorus around about 40
percent of it more or less washes off
the land and either goes into rivers and
then into the ocean or it goes up into
the air where creates nitrous oxides and
nitrous oxide when it goes into the
ocean it's fertilizer still it causes
huge algae blooms and all sorts of other
microorganisms they die they fall to the
floor microorganisms eat there they
proliferate in the secondary bloom and
this happened so much that there's this
creation of this enormous dead zones
there's one in the Gulf of Mexico about
seven thousand square miles one last
year that was discovered in the pay of
Bengal or mapped rather in the Bay of
Bengal for the first time it's about
three times larger it's really enormous
meanwhile the ones the nitrogen that's
up in the air is interfering with the
ozone layer and so if climate change
weren't around this would actually be a
fairly good candidate for our worst
pollution problem even larger negative
if we were since we're collecting them
is shown here this is a diego rivera
mural from 1931 showing his idea of what
the plantation looks like in mexico and
you see the pale-skinned owner lounging
at his ease while all these very
dark-skinned people are working terribly
with the whole thing enforced by the
federales and so that's really the way
things were and what happened was all
these poor farmers suddenly their land
could grow four or five times as much
food it became four times more or five
times more valuable and it became worth
stealing and this guy here you wouldn't
expect him to do anything else and so
there's this big massive wave of people
were pushed off their land and this was
actually encouraged by governments
around the world because they wanted to
industrialize and what they wanted to
have is lots of factory workers and get
everybody in the cities so they could
work there and the result was the
creation of enormous slums in places
like this as Mexico City and conditions
in these slums were just awful this is a
vast dump outside of Manila that my
friend Peter photographed in 2004 its
crowds of kids many of them presumably
displaced farm kids are picking through
the waste 24/7 so this is really a deep
negative and it's the kind of thing that
inspired answer number two and I bet you
were forgettin and thinking that I had
forgotten that to tell you that about
the second answer so this is William
Vogt a much more obscure figure I think
he's really important and maybe at the
end of this talk you'll agree with me if
I was going to be technical I would call
him a neo Burkean perceptual desk Lynch
for bender that's an actual
philosophical term I don't know how to
pronounce it but it's real I'm not gonna
inflict that you and I just call him a
prophet he grows up poor in outside of
rural Long Island when he's 11 days old
his father he camps with the wife of a
local rich person creating a local
scandal that's big enough from juicy
enough to actually make it into the New
York Times the family goes on the skids
he ends up in the slums of Brooklyn but
he's a clever lad and so he gets to go
to one of those schools you hear about
him in New York where they have four
smart poor boys and he becomes the first
in his family to graduate from college
he graduates with a degree in French
literature in the beginning of the
depression and what he had and so what
saves him is the fact that he's an avid
birdwatcher and and it gives you some
idea how bad things were that
bird-watching was actually a career
choice that was a good one for him and
the reason is that he's in New York and
and so he's a he's an ambitious bird
watcher and so he starts paling around
with the ornithologist at the American
Museum of Natural History
they get him one job after the other he
learns a ton about birds and he ends up
in 1939 here off the coast of Peru and
what is here if you can see whoops that
was supposed to be like that I'm pushing
the wrong button here we go this is the
Humboldt Current
it's a if some of you remember your
geography from high school it's a very
very deep cold water current that's full
of nutrients and that produces tons of
food for
it's one of the great Fisheries of the
world these are ancho vetas which are
cousins to the anchovy and he ends up on
these islands here the Chincha islands
which are the circled ones because these
birds have been eating the fish there
forever and ever the they roost on these
islands and the islands turned into
giant heaps of guano or bird excrement
and in the 1860s this became the world's
first high intensity fertilizer and a
major source of revenue for Peru and so
in the 1930s Peru's been mining this
stuff they mined it with slaves for a
long time people work in absolutely
horrible conditions they still like to
keep it going and the birds start to die
and they get very upset and so they call
an American ornithologist no American
ornithologist wants to go there because
the conditions are so bad so they send
William vote and tell him that he is the
expert he like so he goes to this place
here this is a recent photograph that
you can see there's not a single plant
on the thing it's still a big just heap
of guano covered with with birds he
doesn't speak Spanish he's never had any
formal training he has been - no
equipment pretty much he's equipped as
well as Borlaug and he goes there and it
looks like this this is his wife the
poor woman he dragged there and what
she's standing on these are bird nests
there's just a billion of these awful
things creatures and this is his
equipment
this is his bird blind the idea that he
had to conceal himself from the birds
just seems ridiculous to me but
nonetheless like Borlaug he does his
tremendous work and what he realizes you
know well ahead of most people is that
there's this oscillation that's going on
the Peruvians to know about this between
El Nino and La Nina is called n so if
you're more technical and what it means
to him and what he realizes is when this
warm water comes in with El Nino that
causes these rains off the coast the
anchovy knows don't like the warmer
water and they move further out and the
birds who are on these islands can't get
to them because they move hundreds of
miles further out and so all the birds
died or large numbers of them because
there's the the fish population drops so
much
so he realizes there's actually a limit
you can't have but so many birth so many
birds because every now and then
El Nino happens and reduces the maximum
number of possible birds and he realizes
this is like you know he has this
epifanov moment and he says this is what
nature is there are these natural limits
it's called carrying capacity now
carrying capacity is a concept it's
probably most of you learned in high
school biology at the time in 1939 it
was roughly about ten years old it
really was popularized by Aldo Leopold
who was sort of a conservationist saint
who was votes best best friend and it's
the foundational idea of the
environmental movement it is the idea
that nature only provides so much
ecosystems can only yield so much and
after that things go to hell if you take
too much and it's been gussied up and
called a bunch of different names the
current one now is planetary boundaries
and people do these elaborate charts but
what right down to it there's not that
much different from what vote said you
know these things happen there's a limit
and there's not much we can do about it
we have to adjust to these we can't
surpass them and if you go through the
ecological literature you see lots and
lots of things like this this was
published in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences and they
talked about the number of Earth's to
use because the earth as a whole has
this carrying capacity they call here
biocapacity vote put all this together
in a 1948 book called road to survival
that is now forgotten but it's sort of
the keystone text of the environmental
movement if you read that Al Gore book
or the one he did that before that earth
and the balance or the Population Bomb
or Silent Spring or limits to growth or
any of these kind of classics all of the
arguments in there with the exception of
climate change were anticipated in the
road to Road to survival and now if you
think about this what Vogt is telling
you and what Borlaug is telling you are
kind of the opposite of each other the
vote is saying there's these limits and
we have to obey them otherwise everybody
will lose Borlaug is saying no we can
innovate and make more and that way
everybody will win and there's this cook
these two guys
met in Mexico in the 1940s and the
immediately clashed and vote in the sort
of half-hearted way tried to get Borlaug
shut down and then they never spoke to
each other they obviously detested each
other and so they would sort of take
potshots at each other and talks but not
mentioning the other person's name but
you get the idea these two people saw
the same thing they saw these very poor
people in these awfully eroded
landscapes and vote looked at it and
said we shouldn't be abusing the land we
should you know withdraw here we should
learn to live up we should put on our
cardigan sweaters turn down the
thermostat you know all those kinds of
things and Borlaug looked at it and said
no we can eed to give these people
better tools and the argument between
them is consider the present and so
let's took a look at the fact you know
how are we gonna feed everybody in 2050
the theory is that there's gonna be
about 10 billion people and we need to
provide in different people have
different estimates between fifty and a
hundred percent more food so how is it
going right and the wizards answer is
straightforward its GMOs genetically
modified organisms and and when they
talk about this by the way they don't
mean the kind of thing that you guys
have probably heard of like Roundup
Ready soy which is where they take you
know a gene or two from a bacterium and
it found in a waste pond and they
inserted in soybeans so you can spray
herbicide on it we're talking about
something much more grand that bears the
resemblance to typical GMOs that a paper
airplane does to a Boeing 787 and I'm
talking about the sea for rice
initiative which some of you may have
heard about here it'll talk about the
long now Institute from Jane Langdale
who was its director
it's a 20-year 100 million-dollar 16 lab
hundred PhD effort the biggest ever in
plant science and the effort is to
change the way photosynthesis works in
rice this is you know to reach into the
heart of life and it effectively created
new species now I'm afraid I would like
to go into more detail on this I'm
afraid of dragging you through areas of
biochemistry you don't want to go into
so if somebody is a glutton for
punishment I will gladly tell you much
more about this in the
question-and-answer sessions but just
for instance say that they are not
trying to just add something to sell
patented goo they're trying to make a
new species and to give away the results
the thing that I want you to notice
though is that this is the testing
facilities for this and look at the
scale here all this is about is efforts
it only makes sense on a huge scale and
they represent a triumph of industrial
agriculture and we'll all that implies
in terms of simplification and scale and
focus and it's all that the profits hate
so the profits answer is the opposite of
this and my example of it is a guy named
Lloyd Nichols in Marengo Illinois and he
runs a farm that I visited a few times
and it is really an amazing enterprise
it's difficult to take pictures for if
you're not a professional photographer
it could not interest any professional
photographer and going out to Marengo
and taking pictures for me so you'll
have to put up with what I have but he
plants about a thousand different
varieties of crops this is yes these
huge charts that cover all these things
it's an incredible information
processing scheme do geek to deal with
all of this and what he's doing in
effect is recreating or mimicking rather
a natural ecosystem with all the
zillions of species involved and I
should also stress that this is not a
low-tech enterprise he has you know for
winter production he has eight solar
powered greenhouses he has four indoor
sprouting centers it's all based on
precision farming precisely monitoring
everything when I was there he was
testing out these drones which are
connected to his computers I spent
several hours trying to take pictures of
the drones I couldn't do this so this is
a bogus picture that I snatched from the
web but this is what the idea is and
what you're getting here is you know
something fantastically different from a
conventional farm and I went to visit
Lloyd and his neighbor Harry Heinberg
who are who grows a conventional farm
the guys are quite friendly but you can
see from these charts the the
differences between them
the Heiberg farms 1,300 acres and he
just grows two crops you know wheat in
corn
both of which are GMOs and it was
difficult to get it but he sort of
finally said that he got seven or eight
million kilograms
year from them use a tons of high
intensity chemicals and there's nobody
there you go 1,300 acres the only person
working it is is Henry and his son who
works halftime both have high school
degrees and they get massive amounts of
subsidies from the government I mean I
started writing him down and there's
there's many more than this it's just
absolutely extraordinary the number of
ways that our government supports Iowa
farmers and Illinois farmers now the
Nichols farm Lloyd's farm which is next
door you know it's about half the size
it has more than a thousand crops he
doesn't grow any GMOs but this is
basically he said a marketing scheme he
doesn't really have any opposition to
them and he thinks that the little bit
less yield there's almost no chemical
input and the big difference is labor he
has 11 full-time at three times less
part-time employees - these guys have
master's degrees it's a fantastically
complex enterprise that he's running and
he's never gotten a dime from the
government now it's I you know people
have done lots and lots of studies
trying to compare you know quote unquote
organic farms with you know quote
unquote industrial farms and they always
show that the organic farms produce a
little bit less than the organic people
say oh you aren't counting the
environmental damage from this you
aren't talking about damage to
communities and so forth it's very very
difficult to compare all of these but
one of the things that seems to be very
clear is that if you want to have more
farms like this more farms like the
Nichols farm you're gonna have to start
bringing some of these things over here
and the economists when you if there's
any in the audience are immediately
saying no no no the answer is not to
have any subsidies at all and that both
of them fight it out in the marketplace
and I can just say that has never
happened in the history of the world
there has never been as insofar as
subsidies have ever existed there's
never been a nation that is willing to
let its agriculture be unsubsidized I
don't think that's realistic and so the
question is what kind of arrangements do
we want to have because it's quite clear
that the cost advantage enjoyed by the
Heinberg farm has a lot to do with these
with these government policies and the
government policies are of course are
reflections of certain values in goals
and so the fights here which in between
the wizards and profits are very
hard to adjudicate because you know the
the wizard over here I guess Spock is
the wizard
you know what they're looking for is big
centralized facilities that are staffed
by as few as possible so as to let
everybody else have their individual
freedom individual goals and to maximize
personal liberty whereas over here Kirk
you know is they always the emotional
side is what they're looking for is
community and what they're looking for
is a perpetuation of a way of life they
are looking for a certain idealized
relationship to nature and a certain
feeling that the smaller-scale networked
enterprises aren't kind of inherently
more democratic and and and just better
for people than these large
technological enterprises and because
these fights are about values they're
very difficult to resolve and they're
particularly difficult to resolve
because they're usually not described in
terms of what they're actually about but
they're described in terms of oh this is
more feasible this is impractical and so
forth when the other side simply doesn't
care about the feasibility and
practicality of the what they're doing
and these fights ripple through almost
every environmental issue that I've seen
and they have so for decades one of them
is energy supply the fossil fuel
industry really begins in the 1850s in
Pennsylvania was the first sort of
modern oil boomtown and it really takes
off in 1902 in Beaumont Texas where they
have the firm the spindle top oil field
where they this meadow is just convulsed
with oil derricks it's an absolutely
fabulous in gusher of oil that comes out
and totally transforms our society but
all the way through even as the oil
industry is coming up there are people
who are trying to make solar energy and
they want it exactly for the same reason
that solar type people want to have it
today they want small-scale Network
individualized things for communities
and for and for households and so even
as this is happening there's this guy
named Lou show who's running a printing
press out of this solar thing that has
this mirror that boils this water that
goes into a steam engine there's a guy
over here at John Ericsson he's actually
quite famous
as the inventor of the the guy who
designed the u.s. monitor which is the
first steel clad battleship and they're
producing all of these stuff year after
year after year probably the climax of
it is a pure o'healey o4o
in st. Louis during the during the
World's Fair they're 47,000 mirrors it
so creates such intense heat that Birds
hundreds of feet above it actually just
fly over it and drop dead and the idea
is this is what you should have instead
of these you know evil you know giant
centralized facilities but the energy
density as they say of oil gas and coal
is so much greater than the diffuse
energy provided by the Sun and when that
it's economically never possible and
there's all these waves of solar energy
that go right up into the 70s and it
never works because the economics of the
the Wizards are so are so much better
then comes climate change this is a
picture from my friend Peter his
backyard in Napa a couple of months ago
this is his perhaps insufficiently
afraid wife in standing there and you
guys know you're in California you know
that this if climate change keeps
happening this is gonna happen more and
more often now I'd like to degress for
just a minute here one of the things
that we people talk about when they talk
about climate change is you know there's
these people who don't believe in it and
so forth and it's quite curious because
I think neither the advocates nor the
people who don't believe it actually
have much idea about how it works and
because it's sort of an important
argument I'd like to talk for just a
minute about how the basic physics of
climate change works so that if you ever
run into your you know crazy uncle Fred
who doesn't believe in this you can
start quizzing them about their
knowledge of basic chemistry and I can
guarantee you this is a way to at least
end the discussion
so I got my friend Leland who is a
wonderful cartoonist to draw these
pictures so here you have the Sun right
he's bathing the earth with every
imaginable kind of light ultraviolet
microwaves you name it
about a third of that bounces off either
the clouds or dust in the air or the
surface there's a little bit absorbed
notably the ultraviolet is absorbed by
the ozone layer the remaining two-thirds
lands on the air UV not down here it
doesn't land on the air it lands on the
ground or water or vegetation you guys
are clear with this right okay great now
all this different kind of light comes
here most of it's filled with a lot of
drink light so it heats up stuff it
heats up the ground it heats up the
vegetation it heats up the water they
emit infrared light this one type of
light and so different kinds of light
come in infrared light goes out we're
halfway done so here's a weird fact that
was discovered in the 1870s so this is
part of the hoax right this hoax and
goes back to it's actually 1869 a guy
named Tyndall discovered this nitrogen
and oxygen make up about 99 percent of
the atmosphere they can't absorb
infrared light so the atmosphere is
entirely made out of nitrogen oxygen all
this infrared light would pass right
through it and we would be in the
snowball we'd be frozen okay but water
vapor which is just about 1% of like can
take it in and that's a good thing
because the water vapor absorbs most of
the infrared light and then passes it to
the nitrogen oxygen and we have our
present warm earth so that's how the
Apple you know the basic level that's
how the atmosphere works so there's this
little now water vapor doesn't absorb
all the well the infrared it lets just a
few frequencies just a few wavelengths
through and this is a good thing because
just enough energy escapes to prevent
the earth from getting unbearably hot
and here you see here is Leland's water
molecule giving the side-eye to this
particular frequency saying no i'm not
going to absorb you now so the whole
system is works really great you know
the water vapor absorbs most most of it
but enough gets through that it keeps it
at this sort of Goldilocks temperature
but here's the bad guy carbon dioxide it
comes in
and remember this is the water vapor
giving it the side-eye it absorbs by
sheer bad luck for us just those
frequencies that water vapor would
otherwise let through so now when you
have a lot of carbon dioxide almost all
of it
almost all the infrared is being
absorbed in the atmosphere and it gets
hotter that's all there is to it
there's lots of sort of secondary
complications but there is nothing more
to it than that and it just infuriates
scientists when people say oh it's a
hoax because this is basic chemistry if
this is wrong
a whole lot of chemistry is wrong a
whole lot of physics is wrong your high
school fit textbook you can just you
know chew it up and throw it away this
is really really basic stuff now they of
course because there are terrible
communicators they showed diagrams like
this this is the same thing as Leland's
nice pictures but you can see here is
here is the wavelengths there is the
absorption it goes through here and here
is the carbon dioxide sitting sitting
there this is a drawn diagram from 1992
which is redrawn from a 1920s
spectroscopy textbook I mean this is not
new but the big point is again if this
is wrong a lot of basic chemistry is
wrong too now I'm going to give you one
more attempt to get this because I
really think it's we should actually
understand what's gonna kill us if it's
gonna kill us imagine that the
atmosphere is like a bathtub and the
water pouring in is the infrared light
you're sitting there all cozy there's
these little holes in the bathtub
they let the water come out and just
about balance between the water coming
out and the water coming in now take
some chewing gum plug up those little
holes one or just one or two of them
that's all you need to plug up and very
slowly the water will begin to rise and
things will go to hell that's climate
change that's all it is and so again
this is what I scientists go crazy it
isn't like you know they always say oh
there's a 97% consensus there's a
hundred percent consensus on basic
chemistry and physics the only question
is exactly how fast that water is going
to rise and that is actually a big
question so I'm sorry for the digression
but this just infuriates me the people
don't understand this and now we return
you to our regularly scheduled
programming the wizards versus the
prophets okay of course because they
fight about everything else the Wizards
and prophets fight about how to fight
climate change and the prophets of
course
like solar power and small-scale
installations that are networked across
communities and so forth with power
being shunted from you to your neighbor
no giant utilities node giant facilities
the Wizards like nuclear power which has
a smallest footprint for amount of
energy that's put out and leaves the
most room for nature and they have
clashed and the solar guys are trying to
shut down the nukes and you're seeing it
here in California with Diablo Canyon
where California's solar power obsessed
governor is basically shutting down
California's nuclear plants much to the
distress of the Wizards involved so but
the whole question is since we don't
really know exactly how fast the
temperature is going to rise what's up
that it might rise much faster than we
like what are we gonna do if we have bad
luck
we've already had bad luck that carbon
dioxide just happens to sit in there and
block you know like chewing gum blocked
emissions what happens if we cannot
change our our power generation in the
way that we need to either or the
wizards or the prophets way and you
start seeing things like this all the
time this is in Santa Rosa
my friend Peter also took this picture
here and he reminded me that there was a
fire exactly here in 1964 and what
climate change will do is make these
fires not happen every 60 years but
maybe every 10 years maybe every five
years and these things will become quite
hot common and so what do we do to avoid
this if we cannot make the transition
fast enough wizards and prophets of
course have different answers the
Wizards answer is shown here by Mount
Pinatubo and the six on this volcanic
explosion in the Philippines in 1991
they killed a couple hundred million
people a couple hundred scuse me a
couple hundred people and it's through
up into the air way up into the
stratosphere this is quite powerful 20
million tons of sulfur dioxide this
combined with water vapor to make a
whole band of sulfuric acid dilute
sulfuric acid and these tiny glittering
droplets that covered the earth like a
like a veil these droplets are
reflective they bounce back just enough
light to lower the year's temperature by
a degree Fahrenheit for a year or two
and so wizards look at this and say well
look if we really need to couldn't we do
this ourselves
and so they advocate you know it's
called solar radiation management if you
want to be tech
it's geoengineering and the idea is that
you put something up in the air it
doesn't have to be sulfur dioxide
there's less scary sounding compounds
than that that blocks just enough of the
Sun to give us a few more decades to
make the transition and the great thing
is go to a meeting of like the Sierra
Club you know the the profit central and
proposed this and watch people go on
tilt and the reason for that is they
think this is completely insane
they see you know the it's dealing with
carbon pollution by more pollution it's
completely nuts and if you're gonna do
it let's do it and harness natural
patterns and you see from them from the
profit side you see why not do something
like this here is this large ecosystem
Sahara which is not particularly
productive right now has been very
productive in the past why can't we
return it to the past state and the way
you would do this is by planting trees
you get these art of idealized drawings
you plant trees you have desalination
plants along the coast that provide the
the water the trees grow they change the
climate underneath them and a relatively
well-known phenomena and trees are
natural carbon eating machines you can
actually grow these in the theory is in
a few decades you could reforest a
significant part of the Sahara that
would draw down a tremendous amount of
carbon dioxide the the leaves and
branches and dead trees could be used to
fuel the desalination plants and then
you could probably plant tree crops in
there and return this area into a much
more productive state and so if you're
gonna do geoengineering why not do it
the natural way and the point I'm making
here is not to advocate either side or
even to all the way mint in fact making
fun of you decide that's just to
entertain you guys it's a very serious
issue and I probably shouldn't be doing
what I just did but the point about it
is all these are not crazier than
anything else I've been talking about
what you're doing here is trying to make
a vision of the future that is consonant
with your values and just as the people
involved in geo engineers are and so
really the
question is less about practicalities
which is what the discussion is often
mired in and much more about what kind
of world do you do you want to live in
what kind of world do you want to create
both of them involve leaps into the
unknown both of them involve technical
problems that we don't know how to solve
but if we're going to do this you know
we much better off to sort of figure out
what kind of world do we do we want to
live in now limb if you remember here
thinks this entire thing I've just been
telling you is ridiculous if she were
here she would be rolling her eyes like
audibly I mean it would just you know
you'd hear them and because she was
saying you guys are trying to beat
Darwin it doesn't matter whether you're
a wizard or a prophet it's doomed
she'd be hooting with laughter at this
idea and I think you have to take this
seriously you know is our in fact we
doomed and is does Darwin apply do we
are we able to escape this are we
special what is the evidence for it well
this is the best empirical case that I
can think of for us being special in
Darwin and having to roll back that
second Copernican revolution a little
bit this is the world in 1800 is a
political map as you can see it looks
quite different from today but this sort
of political map disguises some of the
biggest differences of that world of
1800 from today in that world of 1800
slavery is universal across the world
there may be a few countries without it
but basically slavery which is one of
the foundational institutions of human
society is everywhere s it has always
been the oldest legal codes we know of
the colleague of the code of hammurabi
for example they're all about buying and
selling people is it it is absolutely
basic and fundamental to human society
yet in a few decades in the 19th century
we basically got rid of it and there is
no society anywhere in which slavery is
legal and accepted certainly slavery
still exists the International Labor
Organization says there's 20 million
slaves or something like that 24 million
maybe but the point is that the
difference between 1800 and now is
enormous
now think also about women in that world
of 1800 there is no place in there where
women oh can decide really who they want
to marry except for maybe certain
aristocratic circles they can't go
college or get educated in most places
women can't own property they are not
allowed to initiate divorces you pretty
much name a thing that you're supposed
to be able to do in society and they
can't do it and this is not an accident
the suppression of women has been
fundamental to human society for as long
as we know there's these sort of rumors
that there were matriarchal societies
but archaeologists had never seen them
basically women have gotten a raw deal
for as long as we can think of and yet
in the last couple hundred years this
has changed obviously we today you know
we know that it's not changing often and
so forth but the point is it's not like
it was in 1800 very many different
things have happened
equally important this was a world
convulsed by violence the amount of
violence that was going on in 1800s by
today's standards absolutely horrific
and yet every study that has ever looked
at these things so far as I know that's
concluded the amount of violence has
gone down down down even when we think
about you know horrific things like
what's going on in Syria or in the Horn
of Africa the amount of violence in the
world has just plunged over the last few
hundred years
there's lively argument about whether
hunters and gatherers were peaceful or
violent so let's just say that we've had
this extraordinarily rapid decrease in
violent over the last couple of
centuries from levels that were enormous
lehigh for thousands of years all of
this is embedded in here and what that
tells me is that human society can
change enormous Lee can change actually
fairly rapidly in something that was
totally fundamental to it like slavery
the suppression of women or armed
violence and so when I look at these
environmental challenges we feed
everybody can we provide enough water
for everybody can we deal with climate
change Gruber right energy for everybody
Lynn's answer is no it's not gonna work
we're gonna hit the edge of the petri
dish and she might be right but all I
can say is if we did all these other
things that I just talked about to be
beaten by climate change would be
profoundly disappointing it would mean
that all right she's right we're not a
special species I hope that's not right
thank you
and you have impeccable slides god
damnit a nicest thing anybody's ever
said to me I'm working on a deck now for
Wisconsin and I'm just envious by the
way I should mention this really is a
book launch tonight they're signed books
out in the lobby and after this talk
after a little conversation here he will
be in the lobby designers more books
just for you okay bye bye bye ranked
alright
almost commercialism raises its ugly
head right you raised slavery at the end
of that as something that changed pretty
quickly was it profits who made that
change or wizards
an excellent question and this is the
kind of thing that there is of course if
you ask economists and historians there
you know the joke about the one-armed
economist because you don't there's no
you don't want to count so there's one
school of thought that says that slavery
essentially became outmoded from the
Industrial Revolution that's the Wizards
the other thought was no it had to do
with the way human beings act and and
what they believed and it took people
like Wilberforce the Darwins for example
and the abolitionist movement to do this
and it took them an you know a few
decades of sustained effort so it so I
think that this is one of those
historical records where both sides can
can feel quite sure that they were
responsible for this yeah no of course
they don't give each other credit so
what's your sense then of k-town is the
model what is the combination of
wizardry and prophecy that might get
ahead of climate change in the next
century or so I think that I have a sort
of a slightly weird take on this I mean
it's pretty quite common to you know
people I know to open the paper and sort
of moan right that things are not moving
fast enough from that's obviously
understandable why but you sort of I
think you all sort of have to remember
how fast things actually move
take the we have the the Food and Drug
Administration which was established by
the Pure Food and Drug Act of 1939 I
think it was it started with a Pure Food
and Drug Act of 1906 and this was a
decade-long battle fought in Congress
about whether ingredients should be
listed on the minutes not whether it was
safe or effective you could you could
actually sell arsenic as long as it was
labeled and the the forces of commercial
of the patent medicine industry and so
forth beat back any attempt to make sure
they were safe and so and this was a
huge fight finally he had to list it
honestly and then went on and finally
there was 1938 the elixir self an amide
scandal which of like a hundred people
or something died from something that
was clearly labeled and the FDA was born
so just think about this the idea that
you have to sell medicine that is safe
and this was took decades so by that
standard I think we're reacting to
climate change with extraordinary speed
it may not be fast enough but you have
to remember this is the shale which
actually thinks and then it's even worse
the federal government first allowed to
determine where they were effective in
1962 so pretty good for climate change
huh we're moving faster than not
poisoning people a little bit different
stakes a few dozen people who take the
wrong medicine to die I know but it's
just an example process everybody all
right so we have a gun to her head it's
probably why we're moving a little
faster you did a nice actually quite
illuminating little premiere on climate
change there on what's happening in the
atmosphere and what's your sense of is
where crisis comes up a lot of climate
change and I think it's partly
reflective of people taking it very
seriously which sounds right and partly
people think it's extremely urgent and
occasionally hear if we don't get parts
per million of carbon dioxide below 400
or whatever
number you set by given date then it's
all over and so this whole urgency thing
cuts in and it's just kind of usually
putting sort of agenda trims do it my
way do it fast you know stop everything
else and just do that do you buy that
frame of people rush because both
profits and wizard say hurry hurry hurry
hurry hurry and I do think that there is
sort of you know see every crisis is an
opportunity you know this is a you know
somebody like Naomi Klein who hates
capitalism says you have to do it do all
this and you have to get rid of
capitalism because you know of the
crisis and so we're then of course
conservatives hate that so the crisis is
kind of a double-edged thing and what it
bothers me about it is that you what
climate sensitivity is do you guys yeah
okay well there's I'm not actually that
was a just people don't I'm probably
most Asians all right so you do but
climate sensitivity is a way of saying
if you put so much more carbon dioxide
in here what will happen right and it's
typically said we doubling it right so
you know in 1880 or thereabouts is
something like 280 parts per million
which is not very much and so you put
560 and what happens and this question
was first asked in 1979 if you double it
what happens and by a US government
report and they came up with I think
it's a was between 1.5 degrees C warming
and 4.5 degrees C warming and since then
the IPCC the International
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change has done five major reports and
each of them has attempted to assess
climate sensitivity what happens if you
double with this and in every case the
answer has been the same the reason is
that these secondary effects that are
not discussed in this are so complicated
that it blurs the the image and in fact
the more we know the more complicated to
gets and there's and the so the fact is
that 1.5 degrees C most people would say
most economists would say that's not
great but we can deal with it and
probably economic growth will be better
and some people's lives will be better
off
four point five degrees C would be a
total disaster and so this is the
problem with climate change that roughly
means two-thirds probability that it's
in that range which means there's a 1/6
probability that is practically nothing
happens or it's an utter total disaster
and so the way I would typically think
of it is suppose I told you you had a 1
in 6 probability of something really bad
happening to your house like a burglar
coming in you would probably feel some
dispatch about going and getting
insurance and so this is what the we is
really uncertain but we face these risk
all the time
and relatively reasonably we hurried to
get some insurance yeah and in fact the
uncertainty makes action I think more
necessary fair enough
Kevin Kelly asks what happens with a
modern society does not subsidize
agriculture wouldn't it just raise food
prices and then things would sort out
with the problem well I think that
that's since there is no modern society
that is ever not subsidized agriculture
we have no idea
we have no idea yeah exactly I I also
think that's unlikely it's a little bit
weak because clearly the agricultural
Lobby in every sense type of society we
have you know not only socialist
nominees account is is the lobby is just
hugely powerful and how is okay you used
to be everybody was almost everybody was
farmers Lobby it was actually a majority
of people representing I think that's no
longer the case that the robots
controlling the you know culture they
know so if you're an economist you would
suggest that sounds great because it
says it says that there is nothing
inherent about this than you and it's
just a hangover from the past and maybe
so but up to now the the control of
lobbies over over this is nobody even
running models what would happen if well
of course different models and and if
you're if you're a libertarian you show
how everything would be really great and
in your models and if you were because
these assumptions involved are the
absolute stripping away of every subsidy
well what is a subsidy
is unemployment insurance a subsidy you
know it is depreciation a subsidy you
know what are you taking away are you
what about the subsidies for people's
houses in in terms of of mortgages and
and and mortgage so forth or the special
rates for mortgage insurance if you're a
farmer and it goes on and on so what are
you taking away exactly you're taking
away stuff that's so embedded into
modern societies that it seems to me a
kind of I mean it's a really good
question but it doesn't seem answerable
isn't that a wishy-washy answer I wish I
could give you a better one well you
know come on libertarians get a state or
an island or a sea state or some guy and
run the experiment this is something
that long now could raise money for
properly
the floating clock and Ely yes tell us
about c4 rice some years ago thanks to
you we have Jane langsdale here talking
about c4 rice and your you were stoked
about it then you're stoked about it now
these big agriculture price they're
really interesting I just think they're
they're really marvelous explorations of
of science you know it of course it
could be that our societies don't want
to want to do this but the knowledge
involved is in the the ambition is just
amazing and so you have these various
you know mega projects if you call in
this and the scale of you know plant
science they're mega projects you know
there's efforts to make self-fertilizing
corn which are you know soybeans have
nodules that have these symbiotic
bacteria on them and the idea is could
you transfer this to to corn there's
wheat that might be able to grow in
saline soils which particularly
important as if sea waters rise and they
filter in for coastal communities and
all these involve these fundamental
reaaahhr texting other so c4 is I'm
really interested in it because I didn't
realize that they didn't tell you the
truth about photosynthesis when you
learned about in the sixth grade and
that which is that photosynthesis sucks
it's like batteries you know how
batteries you know they tell you about
this in chemistry they don't tell you
how crappy batteries are and it and how
difficult it is to improve them
photosynthesis depends on an enzyme
which is a biological catalyst called
Rubisco it's actually got a huge long
name Rubisco was deliberately coined out
of different letters in it sound like a
breakfast cereal this is true it's
really true it's designed to sound like
a breakfast cereal as a joke and then
caught on and and enzymes are like
pedestrians you know they're catalysts
they're like pedestrians who go out into
traffic caused huge accidents and then
run back unharmed themselves to go out
and cause an X accident and so what
Rubisco does is it grabs carbon day in
regular plants it grabs carbon dioxide
and shoves it into photosynthesis and
that the carbon and that's where you get
the carbon from to make the
carbohydrates that are at the basis of
photosynthesis a typical enzyme
catalyzes a few thousand to about ten
thousand reactions per second are
incredibly busy Rubisco so how
potato it does two or three per second
you know it's it's it's like the worst
enzyme ever and it's and then even worse
than that it's like mr. Magoo because
what does it grabs carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide is a linear molecule with you
know the carbon here two oxygens here
and oxygen of course it's also a linear
molecule with two oxygens here you can't
tell the difference between them and so
about 40% of the time it depends a
little bit on the plant it grabs the
wrong molecule and tries to shove oxygen
in it and the intercellular there's this
whole elaborate cellular mechanism to go
oh no we don't want this and to kick it
out of this out of the cell and so it's
lazy and incompetent and evolution has
never improved it right so in fact I did
this I talked to these guys and you know
and we have coffee with them afterwards
and they just I hate Rubisco it's just
awful and and to make up for its
inefficiency and in confident plants
make a huge amount of it and many plants
about 50% of the proteins in their
leaves or Rubisco and what that is
Rubisco has a ton of nitrogen in it and
so when you're putting fertilizer
implants what you're essentially doing
is helping them make Rubisco so if you
could get some kind of end run around
Rubisco you could you know in addition
the plant growing faster you could
actually stop having to fertilize so
much which which would be a tremendous
thing for all these environmental
problems they said so the idea is that
plants about 60 times have evolved
because biologists have you know no
naming sense they're unlike me with
lizard and prophet and catchy stuff they
don't do that
and so they call it c4 photosynthesis
and c4 photosynthesis is where you have
special cells rats to a corn is an
example riggers right but your regular
synthesis regular photosynthesis is yeah
c3 is the name for it and you can see it
if you ever have you ever have mowed
your lawn and your regular blue grass is
c3 and then the crab grass grows
immediately after you mow it and you
know I have three days after you get the
crab grass is up here and there and the
other grass growing just so much crab
grass is c4 regular grass is c3 and the
way it works is they have another enzyme
that grabs the carbon dioxide and then
sit into these special cells that are
wrapped around the veins and these are
where the Rubisco is and it does its
work and it's in this environment that's
practically oxygen free so it can't do
the mr. Magoo bit and it's about 40
percent more efficient and since you're
doing with something that sits like
there's one estimate that I saw that's
140 thousandth of a percent efficient
any increase is a huge deal and so the
idea is to because this has evolved
independently about 60 times the idea is
that most green plants must have
precursor genes you know sleeping genes
dormant genes what have you and the goal
here is to genetically engineer rice
with its own genes and to make it into
the c4 plant that is already sort of
there if I can't do that they want to
take very closely related genes from
another species that's easier to work
for it's for technical reasons but
that's the basic idea and so you're not
dealing with a single gene here you're
dealing with an entire complex of genes
and creating a fundamentally new species
and that's really amazing it's called
[ __ ] with nature that's the technical
term yeah yeah you're really reaching
into the heart and there's a higher
profits down well it's quite interesting
because they don't like the idea of I
mean you know there's sort of what I
think of is kind of bogus reasons where
people cease on
oh this report that it's safe it's the I
just don't think that means that it
holds water because the same people were
typically saying look the IPCC you know
the scientific experts say that climate
change is happening sometimes go around
and saying that all these medical bodies
and scientific bodies that have studied
genetic engineering and find it safe
they're all wrong somehow
and I think you have to go with the
science both ways what I think they're
fundamentally and this is a much better
argument is they're fundamentally
against industrial agriculture which
they see is basically destructive and
not the way to go and so this is this is
propping along a system that was a
mistake to begin with
yeah I had a lot good to say about
profits and yet you haven't had a lot
too good I know I don't
you know I I I but your book is sort of
saying that wizard and the Prophet and
the Wizards are good at some things but
they're blind about other things and the
prophets are sure blind about something
limits is important to have that's how
you avoid the edge of the petri dish but
it's been kind of hard on the prophets
most of this evening so okay well first
and most important is that the prophets
are clearly right you know the earth II
so the earth is finite the earth is
finite right they are right about this
the question is are they relevant that's
a real argument because if the limits
are way way out there then you know
where human beings are we aren't gonna
hit okay so you just undercut that
phrase for no I didn't know no you know
when you people have these planetary
limits and so forth look these are not
you know these are these are for real
possibly okay so you're saying there's a
larger general and wrong and specific no
no no I'm just trying to say these are
very in general they're obviously right
mm-hmm you know if they're if the world
had a hundred billion people in it is
very difficult to imagine that that this
wouldn't be a dreadful mistake mm-hmm
it's not at all clear what happens
between seven and ten billion people
mm-hmm it could be that the you know
people who are measuring the earth are
right I'm skeptical about that because
this is a fantastically difficult thing
to assess you know the factors involved
are just enormous I mean we're just you
know think how difficult those climate
models are and now you're adding and
everything else involved with life and
also the ecological interactions
themselves are extraordinarily difficult
to measure just take the fact how much
carbon dioxide two trees absorb and the
answer is all those measurements were
done in the 1960s with boreal forests
which are the kind of forests in Canada
in Siberia we don't really have a good
measurement of what's going on in the
Amazon and so forth it could be much
lower it could be much higher so I think
it's very important for
wizards to keep in mind that sooner or
later the profits are going to be are
going to be right enough science yeah
well yeah you mean more science and and
I think the best profits say would would
totally agree with us and this is true
with almost every major biological
factor you care to name for example
whether the big thing that came out last
year I was really fascinated by this is
that there's this there are these
methane hydrates that line the the
coasts and which is basically when the
microorganisms you know algae and so
forth die they fall down to the ocean
shore they rot and they reduce methane
and when it when the conditions are
right and cold and there's enough
pressure they produce these structures
called methane hydrates that sit down
there on the on the on the bottom
ice is flammable yes it's flammable I
say they call it and there's just a
fantastic amount of this stuff if all of
it went into the atmosphere that would
be tremendously bad because methane is a
potent climate change mine it first
right well the or but people also say
they could mine it for natural gas and
there's efforts by particularly in Japan
and China and the south and then in fact
a big part of the conflict that they're
all having in the South China Sea is
because this is a ton of methane
hydrates there yeah and they know it's
all about oil and this is the sort of
thing that we're not oil natural gas and
this is the kind of thing that you know
fuels sort of paranoid people saying
that all conflicts everywhere about oil
or natural gas but this one really is
and
and so naturally people in Norway where
there's a ton of methane hydrates are
worried about this and the ocean is
warming up so they wanted to see what
was what was happening and what they
discovered was indeed some of these
methane hydrates are coming up and
that's adding declarant change but also
that is causing you know upward motion
your the rising temperatures in there
and that is bringing up nutrient-rich
the Austrians that and there's so much
photos most occurrence yeah a couple
current type stuff that so much
photosynthesis taking place that it
cancels more than cancels out the effect
of the methane hydrates and now look
that's just one thing that's just one
thing it doesn't mean that climate
change is not gonna happen or anything
like that but it's a perfect example of
how little we understand about these
fundamental biological phenomena and the
profits are totally right to remind us
about about that where they're wrong I
think in my opinion is being absolutely
certain of this and then this is again
about a matter of how do you manage
uncertainty so Norman Borlaug was really
interested in what was called the
population problem yeah and my old
teachers Stanford we're still around
they're still arguing Paul Ehrlich was
also a really interested population
problem and the stances they took were
kind of proper Persis wizard sins and
then Borlaug was basically saying get
people enough food and they'll have
fewer children and Paul is basically
saying the only way people are going to
stop having so many babies because it's
so much fun is to basically have laws
that prevent them for doing it
after necessary put sterilants in the
water supply which is I suppose a kind
of a technical solution aha which has
never been deployed as far as I know
population is leveling off rapidly by
mid-century somewhere between nine and
ten billion maybe then stays there maybe
even goes down who won who made that
happen the prophets or the Wizards and
it's certainly neither I mean the big
profit lactic turns out to be educating
women
and this is one of those tremendous win
wins right because it's obviously better
for everybody you know officially
officially for women but you your we
have all these problems to deliberately
ignore the talents of half the human
race seems totally idiotic to me and so
it's a total win-win and it also turns
out that women who have more
opportunities tend to not want to have
as many children because they they have
children they want to do and so neither
side in this really took enough thoughts
about social science and I was the
criticism would make of both of them
both of these sides is they're much too
oriented about the hard sciences
particularly biology and not interested
enough in ecology and not excuse me in
economics in history in anthropology and
all these other things that really
change the way human beings are and for
example Borlaug bless his soul a
tremendously decent guy really wanted to
help the poor poor really wanted to help
these people that he is working with
spent his entire life was poor farmers
never understood until the day he died
that unless they had better institutions
to protect their property hmm
that tons of the people that he was
helping would be ripped off hmm
well he was good and if they had enough
food that they that's a pretty big deal
the losing your land the other thing
that happened there with this sort of
industrialization scaling up of of
agriculture in the Borlaug mode is that
you needed even it needs seven kids to
run your farm anymore in fact we're just
comparing those two farms and yeah I've
actually wofully I'm waffle back and
forth in this because you know if you're
Borlaug Ian and I don't use that word
actually very much because it sounds too
much like you know a Star Trek alien you
know captain the poor dog you an
ambassador you know so that's why
another reason use wizard of prophets so
if you're a wizard
resistance is futile rage if you're if
you're wizard you look at this and say
look at those people working the farm
they could do so much better they do so
many different things now I think like
wait a minute these people are very hard
to replace by robots you know it's it's
just not gonna happen very fast oddly
enough it's it's the the particularly
complex farms the amount of
mechanization even efforts to study
mechanization is next to nothing there's
a few companies in Germany Davis is just
beginning but for the foreseeable future
we're gonna need a lot of a lot of
people if some of these so you think
like well if some of these subsidies
were swung over and they subsidize a
labor as opposed to machinery you might
get something really dramatically
different and maybe what was a bug might
actually be a feature for the subsidies
in law you know if we're gonna say you
know they would say profits would say I
think you know it's hard argument look
here's some size of machinery once you
actually subsidize people yeah if you're
gonna do this right I don't think is
that a crazy argument to see how that
plays in different parts of America yeah
you know here's something I would
suspect you know the there's a ton of
people who were farmers that I've met in
the Middle West around and without
exception they don't really like the
fact that they can't pay living wages to
their workers yeah and if they had some
help with that I don't think there'd be
a lot of resistance to it pour it on I
like that there's a question from Benji
what would VOC and Borlaug think about
you on musk idea they have humanity beat
multiplanetary what they think about one
musk anyway
yeah and sort of like which Elon Musk
ain't here any of the this is the solar
one of the space one yeah I mean you
know Bora I think what it was would have
open all for the space program you have
to imagine that he would have but the
idea of getting massive numbers of
people out there that's pretty
formidable right the I kind of think
probably both of them would have said
okay that's for the far future in your
future let's worry about getting enough
people to eat and getting enough for
people to eat and maintaining the
world's ecosystems that's a fair
question a kind of a long nail question
who's more comfortable thinking long
term do you think you generally was your
types or proper types probably profit
types I think they think in terms of
long term ecological cycles but of
course so many of them now think purely
in terms of short-term and political
advantage you know when they have these
fights I I had this argument with with a
full-blown prophet about Bill McKibben's
effort there's a full-blown prophet yeah
yeah yeah it was in fact him that was
sort of back ended anyway about the the
pipeline because the National Academy of
Sciences did what I could as far as I
could tell a pretty good report saying
they would have really negligible impact
on climate because that the the tar
sands would just be routed through
trains you know and there be other ways
of doing it and I'm actually pretty much
against the pipeline because native
people don't want to cross in their land
and I think the you know we should
probably give these guys primacy and
allow that to happen
so this but that's separate and you know
if they don't want to cross in your land
why do we forcing it down their throats
it's kind of how I feel about it
but that's personally but I would leave
that aside I went to build you know I
talked to what I said you know why are
you picking this you know why not pick
coal plants which are doing immediate
harm to
this and the back-and-forth in the
argument that the answer that I got was
as I understood it and maybe he wouldn't
agree with this is that this is a
political fight to the death and we have
to show that we can shut things down
that we have to have political power
okay I hate that so that's that's not
that was actually part of you that both
sides are so this is arguing against my
own point that the profits are generally
doing this I reckon just want to before
you say that I recognize that I just
confident making a point that profits I
think use the word manic in that they
would like to see things put in sort of
terms of good and evil they're good not
as inclined to talking truth like that I
mean in general although you have a
wizard type who's running for governor
Mike Shellenberger who seems very happy
in that mode and he's a real pugilistic
type guy and after we're getting to that
point where one asks evening watching
expert you I mean you're gonna go out
and plug this book and fairly tired of
its subject so how are you keeping your
interest alive on projects you might do
oh because this look this is really an
idiotic book to write you know in terms
of practicalities because not only did
okay first I somehow assumed that there
be a biography of Borlaug and vote
because they were actually really
important yeah and there wasn't if any
of you were freelance writers do one
please
so I don't mean I had to be like a baby
biographer like going to archives and
and and so forth and read all their
letters and there's full of surprises
full enough I had no idea about both of
them yeah well I didn't know either and
then the worst thing was actually so you
know I go to vote and I find his papers
which are in the Denver Public Library
and turns out that because he's a writer
he's made a bunch of there's about a
hundred pages of autobiographical
jottings I would think mostly
handwritten and I think great I don't
have to do any more work
I just got it all right here cuz I'm not
writing a full-blown biography it's just
really a couple chapters in this longer
book and so I write at all and
I think you know I should probably fact
check this just a little and um and so I
think like so the first thing I think is
like it says he says his father died
when he was a baby and I think okay well
let's get his father's death certificate
yeah I can't find it and I would come
around I just simply cannot find any
record of his death and so I have a
friend who's a genealogist who puts me
in touch for the professional New York
genealogist and the guy you know goes
and I hire him because I'm feeling so
unconfident and his name is Roger
Jocelyn a wonderful guy and he calls me
up a couple days later and says guess
what he didn't die he ran away with a
twit see and there is a lurid paper
trail and I think oh no and so something
is gonna hijack the book if you do say
no no I don't want to really fight I
just want to get him to the islands
guano islands and then it turns like
this whole other wife that I didn't know
about so all of this took me and then I
said then I had this idea that you know
I should look at how Borlaug II and some
vote Ian's since the words I said I
wasn't gonna use look at these problems
and I had to learn about all these other
just don't do write a book like this led
you down some some wonderful oh yeah I
learned a lot I learned a lot but it
wasn't
how does put this practically speaking
the very best thing that ever happened
to the man family finances
by this man's go get it hardcover okay
yeah I guess that's right I think I like
flinging myself on their mercy right
yeah well I've got a couple ideas one
that I was actually mentioned briefly to
you so this was a set up you think this
is a spontaneous conversation but it's
at all carefully I'll tell ya well the
basic ideas a wonderful book came out in
1978 by Ernst Meier the great biologist
which is a history of biological thought
and it's a terrific book but there's
never been a successor as far as I know
and a lot has happened to evolutionary
thought since then and so I would like
to right if I could write a book is half
as good as his about you know what's
happened since then it would include
then I would be very happy so I was
thinking of a three-part book it's
evolution before Darwin you know all the
various sort of proto evolutions
evolution with Darwin would be the
second part that's probably the most
well known part although in fact you
know new stuff keeps finding the being
turned up very fortunately Janet Brown
wrote these two absolutely huge
biographies that are so I won't have to
you know go as much in the archives and
then evolution after Darwin would you be
the substantial part of the book and
this idea that now we understand thanks
to people like Lynn Margulis the
microworld
and all the sort of ideas we had from
evolution which were basic premise done
large mammals are rather different down
there and that's the bulk of
evolutionary creativity and that's
really interesting and I think there's a
lot to look out by the way as Chris
Thomas who's gonna be speaking here
later this year who I think he's done a
sort of best species type evolution book
since Darwin called inheritors of the
earth that's a good book yeah that's a
good at you know and but it is very much
Darwinian type revolution as is going
now the species of pre-hearing out how
to deal with us and dealing with us like
mad and that's part of what's going on
so we were driving some species extinct
and other species are driving themselves
into existence
thanks in part cause anyway that's part
of what's going on but the microbial
stuff didn't win ever take on evolution
as
yeah well she got into the fight with
the she'd like to sneer at the Neo
Darwinists when she was in a wall with
quite a few other categories yeah yeah
Lynn was she enjoyed yes and so part of
the yeah yeah and so you know so she
would see a SAP like me and think like
how can I get this guy to squawk and for
you
the weird thing is she was actually
pretty nice she's one of those type of
people right and so you know their whole
thing about the idea is that survival of
the fittest in natural selection she
thought you know that exists obviously
it exists she just didn't think was
nearly as important right and I think
over time as massive collaboration which
a lot of microbes do right the symbiotic
dose of you know she used to say the
genes don't care about what your theory
is it's just gonna do what they're gonna
do and so you just have to you know be
prepared that it's just gonna be a total
soup surgery the selfish gene approach
to things no say more yeah no she
thought that this was well there's a
long argument that basically she thought
this was a perfect example where you
need more women in science the unselfish
be no no no this sort of war the thing
with a survival of the fittest and this
sort of chest beating you know and the
sort of stuff when in fact there's many
more cooperative symbiotic or and also
lots of randomness and chance involved
in ways that they you know that she
hated these sort of just so stories
they're just so stories that's the one
thing that Steven Jay Google got right
she was so she was really let people
have it and so she thought that what you
needed to do was get away from these the
these stories which existed primarily in
the tiny cute but basically unimportant
periphery of the biological world that
was the mammals right
[Music]
the about six years probably we want you
back to talk about your well Connie
evolution I hope thank you for coming
today thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]